[Music]
listen let's talk a game of thrones it's
it's coming to an end I know that you
cannot tell me anything that is gonna
happen and they strict with that well
they're very strict yeah Gerber's don't
ya know it's it's it's reached a crazy
level this this year we we actually kept
the scripts and then when we've shot the
scene and we only have it digitally and
then when you've done the scene it just
vanishes yeah it's like it's like
Mission Impossible this will
self-destruct and they're just oh you
better read up quick yeah I'm telling me
a year you have disappointed that it's
coming to an Andy I have you had enough
now are you ready to move on to the next
chapter I'm gonna miss the people and
also I'm gonna miss you know Belle frost
and if that's been amazing just to the
lowest nine years how that city has
changed yeah I also know that we end the
right way and the show ends in its own
terms and when I read the scripts for
the last season I was like wow they
really pulled it off yeah just it's one
story from you know season 1 to 9
minutes hey everybody it's Charlie so we
got a promo or fire in blood which is
coming out later this year there's
actually a giveaway going on for that
that I'll explain in a second but we
also have Nikolaj coster-waldau talking
about the ending of the show it's ending
on its own terms which is code for we're
doing our own version of the ending
we're gonna be paying off all the
moments we set up on the TV show it'll
probably be different from the book
ending in 6 or 7 years or however long
it takes towards our Martin to
completely finish the story so like I
said there's a new round of the giveaway
for that fire and blood book all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
here's my top ten foreshadowing moments
that they will probably pay off now this
way more than this but I just picked my
top 10 so starting with Jamie because
it's his interview I want to die in the
arms of someone I love so ending the
show on its own terms means he's
probably going to die in the arms of
someone he loves namely Cersei or
Brienne but I have a stronger feeling
that it's gonna be Cersei based on some
of the other things on my list here so
it'll make a little more sense in a
second but 9 Emilia Clarke said that her
final scene was supposed to be just a
simple insert shot of her hand meaning
that whatever the scene is you'll only
see
her hand in the frame that implies it's
gonna be a moment similar to what she
saw in her vision when she was in the
burndown iron throne room it looked like
a mixture of snow and ash like it had
been raised in battle so because of the
larger forces at play we know that
that's probably going to happen at
King's Landing
meaning that there'll be some sort of
moment where she goes up to touch the
actual Iron Throne and you just see her
hand doesn't mean that she's gonna die
it just means they're gonna pay off some
of her visions in the house of the
undying number eight flowing from this
battle logic Tyrians prophecy to search
see your joy will turn to ashes in your
mouth and you'll know the debt has been
paid so Cersei is probably literally
going to taste ash in her mouth when
dragons come back to King's Landing
they'll start burning stuff could be the
night Kings army could be searched these
golden companies soldiers there'll be a
big battle they'll probably lots of
Dragon Fire at King's Landing meaning
that she will literally taste ashes in
her mouth seven torment kept talking
about his love for Brienne all the
things that he was going to do when he
came back I'm gonna make her mine we're
gonna get married we're gonna have
babies they'll probably pay that off
when he comes back he'll have some
moment where he acknowledges his
feelings for her and whether or not they
end up together you can decide I would
rather see her end up with Jaime if
she's gonna end up with anybody just so
they can pay off this moment from way
back in season six Jaime saw her first
they spent more time together their
character arcs are more meaningful to
each other so that's what I'll say about
that but like I said Jaime is probably
gonna die in the arms of someone he
loves so I don't think it's gonna be too
much of an issue there's also that
moment a couple seasons ago where Jamie
asked Brienne jokingly if she's still a
maiden she nods I hope that they find a
way to pay that off too but remember
there's only six episodes and there's
only so much space on the sex boat
number six now the reunion Aria and
Gendry had it out before he was taken
away by Melisandre where she said I
could be your family they'll probably
find a way to pay that off but like I
said there's only six episodes I don't
think it's gonna be too much of an issue
I think the show's gonna disappoint
people if you're expecting them to write
off into the sunset together but I think
they'll find a metaphorical way to pay
off that quote-unquote family line that
Aria had five this is actually a pretty
big one they'll finish paying off this
moment between Jon and Ned during season
1 episode 2 where he asked about his
mother we'll talk about her the next
time were together wouldn't it be great
if they had
samwell and bran tell John about Liana
and Rhaegar down in the crypts in front
of Ned statue it would be a funny way to
pay it off because he wouldn't be
talking to Ned but Ned would be there
metaphorically speaking while John was
learning about his mother for when the
three-eyed raven told brand he'd never
walk again but he would fly they've
already kind of paid that off by having
him Ward the Ravens but I think they'll
also take the idea to its logical
conclusion and he'll warg one of the
dragons and control it during the
upcoming Battle of Winterfell three
Cersei has gone full maegor the cruel
I've already done a bunch of videos
explaining the parallels between those
two characters but on the show's terms
she's more like the Mad King because
they haven't really done maegor the
cruel on the TV show I think she will
have a burned them all moment and that
someone either Jaime or one of the other
little brothers will kill her valonqar
style the show's cut the valonqar
prophecy out but there are a number of
characters that could fulfill that so
like I said they have Jamie you have
Tyrion the Hound is also a little
brother in Arya could also wear the face
of one of those other people and kill
Cersei so I will say that I do feel like
Jaime and Cersei stories are meant to
end together which you know sort of
ropes in the idea that he's going to die
in the arms of someone he loves that
doesn't mean that it's not gonna be
Brienne but I do think that Jaime's
death and Circe's death will be tied to
each other and I just I really hope that
they pay that off by having Jaime be the
one to kill Cersei - I believe they'll
pay off the lone wolf dies but the pack
survives again but it'll be in the form
of the dire wolves have a reunion so
right now it's just ghost in Nymeria
that are alive Nymeria has her super PAC
I think there'll be some sort of dire
wolf reunion paying that off like they
did it because the Starks are wolves
lone wolf dies pack survives was all
about Arya and Sansa storyline this
season so they're probably trying to
find a way to extend that metaphor into
season eight but number one biggest one
they'll probably pay off Miri masters
false prophecy Daenerys thinking that
she'll never have any more children they
really beat you in the face with that
during Season seven with foreshadowing
scenes
Daenerys kept telling Jon I'll never
have any more children even John replied
to her this isn't the end of your house
while they were in the dragon pit the
woman they killed your child and husband
might not be such a reliable source
of information now there are a lot of
people that take the theory a lot
further than that people are wondering
if Daenerys is gonna die in childbirth
but the baby will survive there are a
lot of people that are wondering if
they're gonna do the dragon has three
heads but instead it will be triplets I
don't think they're gonna take it that
bar and Daenerys doesn't even look that
pregnant so they would have to have a
really big time jump at the end of the
season and do like a full Lord of the
Ring style montage and I don't know that
they're gonna do that but also - I
should say you know bonus prediction for
things they have to pay off Samwell
riding the book that is the timeline of
events and calling it a game of Thrones
like literally riding the Book of Game
of Thrones that maester ebro's teased
way at the beginning of season seven
when Samwell was still in the Citadel so
that's actually probably the funniest
one like Samwell actually doing full
Lord of the Rings Hobbit style Bilbo
Baggins writing the book that becomes a
game of Thrones but let me know in the
comments if there are any big moments
you want them to pay off that I didn't
mention in the video leave all your
video requests in the comments below and
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Titan hound please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
Daenerys foreshadowing her own pregnancy
and click here for my new Arya again
great video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight